Well that- that generator- AAAHHHHHH!
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier,
And welcome to Sophie's Curse.
Now I just got in the game here because...
Oh!
OH!
OOOOH!
This is NOT what I thought it would be!
OKAY!
I got this game on steam and when I opened it up I had no idea what it was going to be about and-- Holy shit.
Oh my god!
That's so weird-- It's like an old mist style game.
It's like something made from the 90's.
So apparently, this story is that I... am taking care of some old sleeping grandpa-- and that's him in the bed there?
*thunder and rattling noises*
Is that him ?!
So, apparently, in this house there is four lighting devices...
...If that's even a thing
And I have to keep them charged...?
Woah, what the hell ? How do I get to B ?!
I don't know how to get to B !
How the frick do I get to B ?!
To B or not to... What the fuck is happening ?! *thunder and rattling noises*
Who was that ?
Oh my god !
What the hell is going on ?!
Well that's A...
Wha.. I don't want to ch--
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING !
How do i get to...?
Oh, that's B !
Ooooh, okay, I got B !
Huh! I was...
I was at a complete loss for what the hell was going on.
Okay so, the story is you're... *thunder and rattling noises*
...You're hired for some gig...
..."A job"...
...To take care of an old man...
...Who's sleeping in the middle of the night, and then, all of a sudden you're running at breakneck speed through this house...
...Trying to keep these lights on...
...And the generator running.
Cause holy hell,
it couldn't be any more logical than this.
Hey grandpa!
How are you doin' ?
Ya doin' nice?
Ya good ?
[hears something]
Woah...
*thunder and rattling noises*
IS THERE A GHOST IN THIS HOUSE RIGHT NOW?
OR IS THAT THE WIND WHIPPING THROUGH MY HAIR?
Ok
see this is BIZARRE
t-t-this is something that i never seen in  a game,
in the past,
twenty years,
like the click to move around the place kind of style thing,
but its cool!
Like I like it I can dig it
I'm wondering what's gonna happen when I let-
*thunder and rattling noises*
When I let one of the power sources go down,
so as an experiment I'm just gonna let B run-
[hears something]
IS THERE A GHOST?!
Should I be concerned?
Okay-
I think I get the gist of the controls
-check the computer for some goddamn reason
Okay so-
Why is it safepoint..?
What does safepoint mean?! Is that the-
*checkpoint sound*
YAAAAAAAAAA
boo-boop
I made it! I don't know-
Hello? Is there a message or somethin'?
I got to a checkpoint, and there's a safepoint at A now
I dunno what that means..
maybe grandpa move down here
to take a little nap?
*Door opens then slams*
HIIIII!!
Hellooo
Who are you?
*Something smashes*
What was-
*Scary noises - probably Shia Labeouf*
The fuck? OH GOD
I though that was a safepoint?
uh-uh-uhh-aye
OH GOD! *thunder and rattling noises*
What do I do?
Wha-
WHAT THE SHIT IS HAPPENING?!
AHHHHHHH
*weird mating noises*
AHHHH
What the fuck?
I don't know
I just thought random screaming would help me out
*regrets choices*
*thunder and rattling noises*
Ah huh, okay
Oh righty then
Anybody else in this house of Hell wanna-
*thunder and rattling*
tell me what's up?
Grandpa! GRAndpa! GRANDPA!
There's something in the house!
And apparently wants to KILL ME, maybe...
I don't know for sure...
Hard to say
And apparently there is still a problem with A
How do I fix the problem with A?
*thunder and rattling noises*
What do I do?
I DONT KNOW HOW TO DO IT!
Do I just keep cranking this yank
until it just gives up on me?
give me the PUDDING!
give me the CANDY!
Make the Jack POP out of the BOX!
I dont know
What do you want from me?
Alrighty then
Just gonna surf porn on the computer
I know theres an error!
OH what is that?
Whaat?
Ohhh
Owhhh
*thunder and rattling noises*
Okaayy
What?
Wooahh heyyy
EyyyeyeyyEYEYEYYEYEY!!
EYYYEYEYYYY
*Ghost screams*
AHHHH FUCK YOOUUU!
Whhaat the fuck?
OHhh okayy
Try that again!
I didn't know that I was suppose to do a big ol' dang ol' puzzle
and if one light goes out some-
one by the name of Sophie
is come murder your face off!
rip your face off, put it on her face so that she can enjoy a little face action
ugh..
face on face ...
sexy times
alright let's try this again...
Not that I know exactly what I'm doing...
but I have a general idea now
that I need to repair...
...these devices...
GRANDPA!
[hears bad noises]
tha- thu- thas not good sounds...
I know good sounds when I hear them and it was not that
whatever I ain't.. I ain't choosey...
Anyway back to my porn...
uh huh...
I don't get what safepoint...
*hitting glass sound*
What efcabababa?
What the frick was that?
*creepy grudge sounds*
Well that- that generator
*Ghost screams*
AH FUCK YOU!
W-WHY!?
WHAT DID I DO?!
WHAT THE FUCKKK?!
WHAT THE SHIT MAN?!
WHAT THE FUCK!?
CAN I GET SOME ...
Don't let the lights run out- I didn't read this!
Sophie can be... pretty mean
Use safepoints!?
Whenever you're in a safepoint means nothing can happen to you unless the devi-
what?! Oh god...
Oh man if you're charging a device and Sophie makes a creepy sound it means she's behind you..
...stop charging immediately
WELL I SHOULD'VE READ THOSE INSTRUCTIONS!
GOOD GOD THAT'S A LITTLE FINICKY DONTCHA THINK?!
alright. let's give this another go
See if I can do a little better
so if I hear any creepy sound, she's behind me
breathing on the nape of my neck
giving me...
giving me gentle smooches
*kiss sound*
ever so gently
and then she screams and rips my face off
but that comes after the gentle smooches
alright, so I need to check the computer to make sure where the safepoint is
*thunder and rattling noises*
*fart noise*
Safepoint's at D at grandpa's room
Nothing bad... can happen to me up there
mm-hm
mmkay, I like this
This is good, this is the things that I like the most about life
breathing
walking around
looking at porn
yelling at grandpa
eating a papaya
fixing a tire
getting out of bed
masturbating
other things I like about life
looking at paintings
ah shit.
*hitting against glass sound*
well that didn't sound good
sounds like someone might've broke in and tryin' to eat my face off
alright
okay...
okay got it!
someone crying nearby
don't like that
that ain't good
Imma go back up to the safe zone
Nothing bad can happen to me in the safe zone!
shit dude
SAFE ZONE!
I love a safe zone!
Grandpa, you're in the safe zone
You know what's goin on
*breathing sounds*
Well you know I gotta ch-
AAHHEYYY
That didn't seem very safe!
I'm in my safety zone!
You can't penetrate my bubble of safeness!
I've got triple-layered condoms on for no reason!
I'm so safe!
If you think you can even g-
... get close ...
The answer is you cannot!
Let me make sure my safe zone is still in the proper safety zone
*thunder and rattling sounds*
Yeup still is!
I'm going back up
ah.. f- sh- for fuck's sake man!
for fuck's sake!
HI
WELL THAT DOESN-
*ghost scream*
AAHHH FUCK YOU
WHAT WAS I SUPPOSED TO DO?!
RUN AWAY?!
I DUNNO!
I DUNNO HOW TO PLAY!
Sometimes Sophie likes to appear at locations learn these locations and try not to look at them for too long...
...if she appears, run the opposite way
OH! T-THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
HAH HAH HAH!
God damn it.
Let's try this one more time
I'm gonna give it one more go
and then I'm gonna take a second to learn how to play
before I play anymore for you guys
hehe... oh man.. alright
where's my safe zone?
oh, up with grandpa!
I love being with GRANDPA!
He's my man man!
He's my PA PAW
MY PA PAW IS GONNA BE WITH ME FOREVER
Just gonna stand here and enjoy the sounds of rain...
...and thunder...
... and the sounds of crap hitting the insides of my underpants
I'm not in my safe zone
Why am i standing here?
Oh... titty sprinkles. Come on!
AH FUCK YOU! WHAT THE FUCK!?
WHAT DID I DO!?
I DID NOTHING!!
WHAT DID I - DIDIDO WHAT?!
HOW IN THE BALLS?!
AGHHH
GOOD GOLLY SOPHIE!
Alright that wasn't a legitimate try
That was not a legitimate try
I dunno what the hell happened there
but that was not a legitimate try
Sophie is just such a dick
Back up with grandpa
still the safepoint so I'm gonna go straight there
and I'm not gonna dick with nobody!
fuck this
til the first thing breaks...
then i die
right grandpa?
first thing it breaks on you, you just keel over and die
Good lordy
Well that's not good sounds
alright I got it.... *mumbles* little bit of that action...
goes there there there there
five six ni- oh shit
five six nine zero
all on. We're good!
okay, back to the safe zone
Fuck this shit, I'm out!
[singing] Oh fuck this shit I'm out!
[singing] Oh yeahh fuck this shit I'm out
[singing] Let's get out of here
[singing] Fuck this shit I'm out
*glass breaking sound*
Oh god. Oh god! Gonna die.
Gonna die. Gonna die. Gonna die.
Why is it not charging?!
OH GOD! SHE'S GONNA KILL ME!
AAAHHHHH
NOT HERE! THERE!
GO THERE! CHARGE!
WHY WAS IT NOT CHARGING B?
eh shit.. I'm gonna die. I'm gonna die. I'M GONNA DIE!
Any minut- OH NO DON'T GO T- STOP!! STOPPP!!!
OH GOD NO!
I MEANT TO-
AAAAAH!
GET IT GET IT GET - AHHHH CHARGE IT
IT WON'T CHARGE. IT'S NOT CHARGING
OH GOD WHY AM I NOT IN MY SAFE ZONE?
HELLO GOODBYE OOHHH FUCK THIS
OOOHH FUCK THIS I'M GOING TO MY SAFE ZONE
WOAHHH FUCK YOU
FUCK YOU
NOOO GO TO THE SAFE ZONE
Ugh god
AAYY!
ALRIGHT!
OKAY!
NICE!
*thunder and rattling noises*
I LIVE!
FOR ANOTHER DAY!
I GET TO CONTINUE MY PATHETIC PITIFUL EXISTENCE!
ALRIGHT
*glass breaking noise*
Uh oh... uh eugh..
eugh AHHH
FUCK YOU
*bumblebee noises?*
*continued bumble noises?*
oh that ain't good
where's the safe zone?
I dunno... fuck me
God that's not the safe zone!
I'm trying to get to the safe zone!
oh f...
oh nevermind then! I guess...
AH FUCK !
W-ah-- fuck f- f- f-
I'm outta here bitch!
WOAHHH K
alrighty then...
wo doo- dooo -do do
woah doo doo do do!
Hey safe zone
I DON'T FEEL VERY SAFE!
ok...
holy shit
What is that sound?
That's a new sound of ... badness
I don't get a checkpoint until 10...
I think
I gotta survive until 10?! Holy shit
holy.. SHIT
I didn't expect this game to actually get me
like... it just seemed like a ...
y'know... generally one of those indie horror games
I had no idea about this game before I got into it
holy crap...
I was sorely mistaken
oh boy
go... go go go
eughh
charge it up
For some reason this one just doesn't work
That just... it just doesn't charge
Safe zone is still D
so I'm just gonna go up there right now
forget this
Maybe if I just stay in...
I DIDN'T DO IT I DIDN'T DO IT
I DIDN'T DO IT
I'M IN THE SAFE ZONE
NOTHING CAN HAPPEN TO ME
oh... it is dark...
AH FUCK YOU
WHAT?? I d- whatt?!
BUT I WAS IN THE SAFE ZONE
YOU SAID NOTHING COULD HAPPEN!
Oh man
ugh they got me
okay
That's all for this episode
I'm gonna try this again
This is actually pretty interesting
but in the next episode
I'll make sure that I actually keep it very dark
DARK
In my room so that I get the full atmosphere treatment
so thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what better way I can approach this game
and you can play this game for yourself, it's on Steam
I forget how much it costs.. but link's in the description
Thanks again everybody!
and as always, I will see you...
...in the next video!
Buh - Bye!
[outro music]